welcome to Sophie and comme Sophie
shevardnadze the recent exchange of fire
between Hamas and Israel has sparked
fears of another Gaza war is the Middle
East peace process on a verge of
collapse well today I talked to a Hood
Barak former Prime Minister of Israel a
hail of Hamas rockets over Israel has
rocked the nation sparking military
strikes on Gaza civilian casualties and
even leading to his railey ministers
resigning shaking the ruling coalition
will the ceasefire hastily put in place
last for much longer
while Israel's reluctant restraint
helped stop another looming Gaza war or
only embolden Hamas to carry out more
attacks who'd maroc the former Prime
Minister of Israel
welcome to the show it is great to have
you with us so mr. Barack the latest
estimate the latest escalation in Gaza
broke out after two hamas commanders
were killed in a botched Israeli Special
Forces raid Hamas fired hundreds of
rockets into Israel in response while
Israel the planes bombed a hundred of
sites in Gaza over the past few days now
as a military man tell me why provoke
Palestinians if it's known in advance
that any sort of undercover military
action there will end up in heavy
response from the militants I cannot
fully explain the Palestinian behavior
but that threatens the normalcy of life
of our citizens around the Gaza Strip
and they compelled the IDF to response
very aggressively the story usually or
mainly through air attacks and destroy
some sensitive installations of Hamas of
course it doesn't end the whole story
but as of now and we are talking it's
much more quiet and let's hope it would
be
it will remain quiet if it won't remain
quiet I would not be surprised if the
government will order the Israeli
Defense Forces to eat even how shallow
how do which might cause more collateral
damage usually and
damage to Hamas and will escalate the
directions which are bed I think for
both sides so Egypt and the United
Nations have been trying to broker a
ceasefire between Hamas and Israel for
several months already and just when it
seemed to be create upon Israel
conducted this secret rate in Gaza now
from the outside it looks like Israel is
kind of sabotaging this peace process in
your opinion is Israel really interested
no no it's just a coincidence this kind
of operations they are quite well but
when they are needed and they're needed
for good or crucial security needs
usually they never come into the public
eye the guys know how to do it without
being exposed along the way so it's a
basically something that happened
against I will wish for su and but it
happened in a moment which was sensitive
and probably helped this to take another
24 or 48 hours before since fire came
into existence now Israel's Defense
Minister Avigdor Lieberman has resigned
and he called the ceasefire which Hamas
and Israel have eventually signed up to
a surrender to Hamas terror
do you agree yeah you know I belong to
the opposition with so I'm how Street
criticizing our own government for being
not not not not more divisive but more
thoughtful about our attitude towards
Hamas so I agree that basically our
government is yielding to Hamas and the
fire it's not a secret that it's erious
in what the head of Hamas he decided
went to open file he decides when to
stop it and him I decide when to resume
it it's not our government but my
criticism is not about our government
that did not order the ante up forces to
take over Gaza because our and faucet
can take over Gaza Strip within several
a few days but the question is what we
what shall we do there afterwards no one
would come to replace us to sit on our
bayonets and control Gaza so we don't
have anything to gain from we conquering
the Gaza Strip my complaint on our
government that they are not using the
last four years since the last wider
operation in order to make sure that we
are capable of inserting a wedge between
the almost two million Palestinians in
Gaza Strip and the Hamas Israel has an
interest to weaken Hamas Israel has an
interest to make sure that life are
normal that enough hours of electricity
enough enough equipment in the in the
hospitals the quality of water is make
the potable water so we don't have an
interesting in human suffering in Gaza
and our government some of fail to do it
they fail to realize the strategically
we have to strengthen Abu Mazen the PLO
in Ramallah and to weaken some us in
Gaza not the other way around so
liberals party has left the coalition
government and the Jewish home party
threatens to follow suit unless its
leader Naftali Bennett gets the seat of
Defense Minister could this be the
beginning of the end for Netanyahu's
coalition I mean how could its potential
downfall affect or impact the peace
process you know in Israel we are going
to have anyhow its most by next October
we have new elections so it's all only a
may a question whether election will
take place in four or five months from
now or ten or eleven months from now
that's the whole difference but as a one
of the informal member of the Opposition
in Israel I still I really believe in
hope that this event will accelerate the
falling down of Daniels government its
replacement by a better government for
Israel in Israelis so the army wanted
the system
but obviously Netanyahu's allies do not
and there were demonstration is in
Israel demanding war do you think the
Israeli public wants another Gaza
operation you know we have a phenomena
that we were acquainted with
unfortunately because we had probably
half a dozen of routes in in Gaza in the
last 10 or 15 years basically everyone
is elated and clapping hands applauding
when you enter Gaza when you start a
major operation but usually after what
will become clear that the only
achievable result is to bring back
relaxation under basically the same
terms there is a lot of frustration so
what we see in our streets is a a
eruption of emotions because the
government really abandoned for eight
months now the people along the other
stream you know when when Tania visited
the the soccer the football matches in
in Moscow the people around Gaza I was
suffering he never came there to see
them he preferred to to fly to Moscow to
see the kind of football matches so it's
basically the feeling is of frustration
their life are not normal children are
going under trauma you have always to be
within 15 seconds from Sun shelter that
deadness not normal life and there is a
price for it and the government pays the
political price of being unable to to
shape a consistent strategy with with
the samarth in Gaza and the consistent
strategy doesn't have to do with the
shooting actual shooting go choosing
targeted is a metaphor the generals the
government doesn't shoot a target but
the government should shape a strategy
which aims at region is imagine and
strengthening of imagine that what they
are failing to do 70 years ago Israel
started were their handicaps
by enemies having to fight to prove its
right to exist and now look it's still
the same for Israel it has normalized
its existence and there's still not a
single friendly neighbor and the Arab
masses hate you
terrorists target you sure you can bomb
them all away like you did in 67 but
does Israel have a chance to become an
accepted player in the neighborhood not
just a toughest and the scariest kid on
the block I'm confident that we can it
might take time do we need patience
nations are not developing positioning
within their neighbors overnight but and
we have to bear in mind that you know
the way that a person cannot choose his
parents a nation cannot choose its
neighbors their whoever they are but
there is a huge difference seventy years
ago when the UN General Assembly decided
about partition plan making two states
in Palestine a Jewish state an Arab
state Israel accepted it in spite of the
fact that our state was supposed to be
three Canton's all be connected without
children without even a vote to
Jerusalem and the Palestinians rejected
didn't try to kill the baby Israel
before we can stand on our feet so we
warned against all odds and we are not
going to be apologetic about it anymore
it's the moral burden of responsibility
for the whole tragedy is on the other
side which rejected at the right time
and once and again the proposal from
outside I was fifty years later a prime
minister I proposed to alpha to put an
end to the whole conflict s truce I'm
compromising and he rejected it and
deliberately to tell so we do not feel
morally responsible but at the same time
it's not true to say that nothing have
changed fifty years ago at the six days
war our most brilliant triumph the
Israel government immediately said that
except for Jerusalem we hold the rest of
the the occupied territories as a
deposit for negotiating peace the Arabs
gathered in hell
and decided that no recognition no
negotiation no peace whatever had been
taken by fault will be brought back by
fault but since then we have 40 years of
peace with the strongest country in the
Arab most important Arab country Egypt
40 years of peace it's not ideal peace
it's not like the peace between you and
I know Belarus but it's peace and it
stood even when the Muslim Brotherhood
under multi-well empowering in Egypt
they didn't dare to country we have 25
years of peace with Jordan the longest
borders not just my government but bebés
government try to make peace even with
Assad Assad the father not the son and
we failed and for 15 years we have a
Saudi Arabian proposal for peace in
exchange for basically a bottle based on
our own 67 between us and a Palestinian
state with some land swap and there is
Arab League proposal so we cannot say
that nothing can change we cannot say
nothing had changed it's true that the
problems are not it over there are
always new enemies the recent ones were
in Qaeda and later - and we still are
not fully quiet but real strong we are
fighting and my difference with our own
government government is that I believe
that Israel is so strong we're the
strongest country thousand miles on
Jerusalem we can afford considering how
to negotiate the peace out of strength
and self-confidence we don't have to
risk ourselves but we have to change
dramatically situation even if it takes
time and takes certain kind of
compromises ok mr. Berg we're gonna take
a short break right now on one we're
back we'll continue talking to a dude
Barak former Prime Minister B's or I'll
discuss in the troubled Middle East
peace process stay with us
[Music]
we're back with a hood barack the former
prime minister of israel discussing the
prospects of the israeli-palestinian
peace in the light of the latest
escalation now mr. Barack as would
already mentioned before Israel's
relations with its Arab neighbors have
always been bad most of them still don't
recognize the State of Israel but lately
we see Netanyahu Penghu is a two man
first in two decades then this overtures
to Riyadh is it working
can we really talk about Israel's
normalization with the Arab world you
know it's better than than what we
worried about and in less than what I
hoped for you know we basically visited
the oh man 20 years ago I was 22 years
ago I was i Foreign Minister of Israel
endorsement palace and we traveled all
around the region we met informally with
Arab leaders all around so it's not not
something new but basically there is
some truth in what you have said in the
recent three years there is a a great
common interest to Israel they emulate
Saudi Arabia Egypt and Jordan it is to
corner to put it bait the Union
hegemonic and nuclear intentions to
struggle together against radical Muslim
terror and to create a counterweight to
the shade banana which stretches from
from Tehran to to Damascus a total
terror but the Damascus Beirut so these
elements a well on the table they should
be used and we seem to be missing it who
isn't it that it cannot fly together we
cannot ride on these common interests
without being ready to deal seriously
with the Palestinian issue not because
the autocrats in the soon I'd Arab world
have certain sentiments tow for the
person probably they don't read but the
people said those autocratic leaders in
in a bit in Saudi Arabia in the
they cannot sit safe on their own chairs
if and except Israel publicly as a
legitimate member of the family of
country of state in the reason in the
region if the Palestinian still and the
permanent Israeli control and that needs
certain change and I think that the what
we can get from the Arab world from
these days through night Alliance is so
important that it justified certain
compromises with Aveda Palestinians in
orbit in order to enable it to fly so
our government of failing to do it and I
think that that it could be changed
former Israeli prime minister who don't
believe that Mahmoud Abbas is the only
Palestinian leader able to bring the
two-state solution to life but his part
is actually at loggerheads with Hamas
whose official line is to destroy Israel
in European how big of an obstacle is
this Fatah Hamas confrontation for the
israeli-palestinian peace process can
Israel reach a peace deal with the West
Bank Palestine and ignore Gaza I don't
think you can ignore Gaza and when we
left Gaza some 12 fields ago 11 years
ago no more than 12 we hope that the
Palestine Saudi formal Abu Mazen will
control the whole area somehow the white
moment from their point of view Hamas
took over and change the election but
Israel has an interest not in the
continuation of these detention as some
Israelis believe including the
government I think that I will real
interest is that somehow they will get
united under a Palestinian Authority and
over molander Abu Mazen because Abu
Mazen with all his kalfa weaknesses is
still a Palestinian leader which prefers
cooperation and living side by side over
violence and he cannot stop all violence
and probably doesn't want to stop all
violence and we have many complaints
about him but nothing to come
Kamath hamara murderers with whom there
is no put even possibility of any
negotiation and that would make them the
favor
faith favoured kind of player on the
other side by our right-wing government
was the right-wing government they are
talking about putting an end to it they
find himself unable unready to really
try to destroy Hamas at the same time
that they focus their efforts on
weakening Abu Mazen and in this regard
aldomet is right we have an interest
together with Egypt Saudi Arabia the
Emirates and other to strengthen Abu
Mazen to make him the one he cannot come
to Gaza on Israeli Barnett's but
together with the Egyptians and others
and Americans we can create a situation
where the Palestinian people in Gaza
might have a second shot whether they
should prevail over Hamas so Trump is
promising to release an actual Mideast
peace plan in a couple of months but
seeing how Washington has lost a trust
of the Palestinian side after an opening
of the u.s. embassy in Jerusalem do
using the United States still can be
relied on for a mediation will
Palestinians even look at the plan that
he's proposing I think that the
Palestinian are over exaggerating the
meaning of the American statement I
think that this statement should have
come 77 0 views ago for 225 years ago
after the Congress passed a resolution
it was for many reason delayed by
previous president I don't think that in
any way the moving of American Embassy
to Jerusalem exclude the possibility
that once the Palestinians comes to
their mind and strike a deal with Israel
and the Americas will move the embassy
to the Palestinian state to wherever
their capital will be if the capital
will have a part of it in in the suburbs
heavily populated Arab suburbs a New
Jerusalem Oh on the eastern part of
Jerusalem I don't see I don't see any
reason to over exaggerate but I shoot me
that the real obstacle now to have the
Trump plan being executed successfully
is the lost of trust between Israeli
leadership and Palestinian leadership
there is not a single drop of trust now
each side whenever something is put on
the table tried to repel the blame game
both sides assumed that it will come to
a deadlock and the the real game is how
to make sure that the other side will be
blamed for the failure and the recently
the Palestinians apparently lost trust
in the American side as the honest
broker that's a quite poor starting
point but still because I'm a eternal
optimist in a way I think that we should
always look for a way to go over the
obstacle and try once and again to I to
which a relaxation it's better than then
whoa I spent my life fighting I tell you
we are ready to fight we're stronger we
know how to fight but profoundly we
prefer and should prevail relaxation and
normalization of the relationship even
if there is no partner now among the
palestine who is ready and capable of
doing it we should probably take certain
unilateral steps to start the divorce
the separation from the palestinians but
do it in a way that will not will not
destroy the chances of a palestinian
state in the future once they come to
they'll do the census and try to do it
so let's talk a bit about Iran
you have said that Iran doesn't present
any existential threat to Israel I agree
however the current Israeli government
is just obsessed with the threat from
Iran it's always around this around that
the bomb the whatnot why is Israel so
nervous about Iran's influence in the
Middle East
Oh basically we don't like the Iranian
behavior don't don't be misled by my
remarks you know you one is a major
threat to the stability in the Middle
East and
to Israel in the longer term what I've
said is that as long as the agreement is
still in power and as long as the
Iranians are following basically the
letter of this agreement it delays their
potential threat to Israel by years
probably a decade or remo it's too early
to - no we shall never let the Iranians
resume their efforts to become a nuclear
power
and we should be ready to coordinate
with the United States or even
independently to block them from
becoming nuclear military power but
having said that I don't think that
there is any immediate existential
threat from Iran in the short and a
midterm level and we have other problems
like you know creating these Alliance
original alliance with the moderate soon
I'd to promote the the arrangement with
the Palestinians to prepare the ground
for a separation or divorce from the
Palestinians to help the situation be
that we will have a one palestinian
purple not two of them and so on so we
have a different priorities the
government is a you know we have a
populist extreme right-wing government
ultra nationalist which which the Gardel
satisfaction the sense of the election
and and the identity from identifying
demos from without and traitors from
within that was the practice of auto
Italian movements all along history at
least in the last 200 years and we saw
it in other places leading - Nowell and
we still believe that we are strong
enough we are a we are so strong that we
can afford being much more realistic not
being always worried and kind of haunted
by demons around us or by traitors from
within there are neither demos no
traitors but real threat that should be
dealt with all right mr. Burke I just
have time for one last question so I'm
gonna ask you to answer briefly if
you can israel has priced the united
states for resuming sanctions against it
on at the same time tehran has
reiterated threats to resume uranium
enrichment now you have said that iran
deal was bad but until now it prevented
Iran from developing nuclear weapons is
it still better for Israel to have some
deal in place than no deal at all there
is difference between us here you know
first of all I don't like to deal with
milk that had already been spilled so I
saw that the the Iran deal was made and
but once it was signed it became part of
the reality I saw that present rapid
other ways to resume negotiations about
spreading terror or developing missiles
or any other issue which was outside of
the deal and to try to negotiate it but
once he announced the sanction there
part of the issue a part of reality
it creates certain economic stress
within Iran but our experience make it
very little hope that this will destroy
the ayatollahs regime and they will find
some way to overcome I don't believe
that they will break out and try to
assume a fully fledged nuclear effort
but from new arrangement probably might
be found a down the stream I think that
we should be clear we have nothing
against the Iranian people the gifted
great people it's only about their
Tula's and I told the intention to
develop nuclear weapons and their
threats to eliminate Israel somehow from
a pen history we are strong enough we
are not afraid but we have to make sure
that either independently or together
with the United States our community
will make sure that Iran will never
cross the line into military nuclear
capability and think that this is
achievable alright mr. Burke thank you
very much for your interview for your
insight pleasure talking to you we're
talking to a hood Barak former Israeli
prime minister discussing the latest
escalation in Gaza and whether it's
pushing the israeli-palestinian peace
further away that is it for this edition
of Sophie Emeco I will see you next time
[Music]